thank you for joining me and uh yeah we
have a yuletide feast is it a your log
what is it what's going on in the world
of uh log files so there's been a an
interesting i mean
exploit maybe bug
feature pick your appropriate um sort of
word to describe it that's appeared in
the last few weeks
pick your own word to describe it in a
package called log for j2
which is a thing that michael talked
about a bit that adds on to java that
enables you to log things
actually that's that's a little unfair
because half the problem isn't in log4j
it's actually in another part of java
called jndi
but we'll come to that let's let's start
at the beginning as it were so are you
sitting comfortably then i'll begin when
you're writing software particularly
software that communicates over the
internet whether that's just receiving
data or processing data or sending data
one of the things you often want to do
is to log what's happening you want to
keep track of what data came in how did
i process it what results did i produce
that sort of thing so that if something
goes wrong you can look back at those
logs and think okay i got this data and
it produced the wrong answer or i got
this and someone was trying to hack into
my system and i can see where they came
from i can sort of see what was going on
i've got some sort of record
of what was going on in my system and
one way you can do that is you can write
that into a text file you can print it
out to the screen capture that into a
text file and things
but often when you're doing these things
your log files get more complicated you
might want to log them into a database
you might want to merge logs from
several different packages together and
so there's a package called log for j2
which is managed by the apache
foundation which people use
a lot
i think the best way to describe it uh
air oxygen water perhaps equivalent for
logging in the java community i mean
it's it's it's used everywhere if you
look at where this is hit microsoft
apple
amazon
apache you name it think of a company
name i bet they've been hit by it me
i don't run a company but mike's been
hit by it personally so it's used
everywhere so it's it's a big deal this
um
thing because it's used everywhere what
what's happened with you mike then well
i mean it's not too too much of a
disaster for me personally but basically
we're running a rest api
um as part of some of our research that
allows us to utilize some of our gpu
compute infrastructure remotely right
now as it happens it's not currently
turned on this api so i'm not
immediately vulnerable to it but i'm
very aware that i'm using log4j for
logging
and i'm gonna have to go through i mean
you know quite simply i can update log4j
but what i really need to be doing is
going and making sure that i'm not
passing any unintentional user input
into my logs right and off the top of my
head i can't remember so this is kind of
this is kind of the problem right you've
got this you've got you can log anywhere
in your application any amount of data
what am i logging well i'm going to have
to find that out and make sure that i'm
not putting something where it shouldn't
be and it's going to cause this problem
that's so that sort of alludes to yeah
what the problem is then steve so over
to you then maybe so yeah so mike's been
using this to log things and
one of the things as we said is that you
log is the data coming in because from a
security point of view
if someone hacks mike's server and i
suspect it's not that hard to do because
mike wrote it um then you can
want to be able to track back and find
how steve hacked into it and so you can
look at the log and you can see oh steve
sent this set of information to it that
caused some sort of exploit he then got
root etc and things so one of the things
you will log a lot
is untrusted data it's data that's
coming in from sources that you can't
trust
now that's fine
except that log4j has a lot of features
which make it
very very nice for developers to use
because as well as logging the data
that's coming in you're probably going
to want to log other information about
your system what operating system it's
running on what version of java it's
running various stats about your own
system and so what log4j does is it
enables you to
substitute in the strings that you log
so you just log in plain text strings
you say log this and it logs it wherever
you want that log to go
what you can log are variables you can
sort of say dollar curly brace something
curly brace and as it processes it'll
take that dollar curly brace and replace
it with some string that's defined i
think it's in the hash table equivalent
um that you set up when you use it or
there are some that can be pulled in
things like the java version and so on
so you can sort of log useful
information alongside the data
that's coming in
now that sounds fine that sounds
useful it sounds great in fact
except
that it does this recursively
so
when you
log something
it'll go through in any place it sees
dollar curly brace it'll replace that
with a string but if that string
contains dollar curly brace it'll
replace that with the expansion of that
string and so on so it's just a
recursive process
but this also means that it will
do that on any untrusted data that you
give it
so if i sort of make a web connection to
mike's server and mike thinks i'm going
to keep track of what's going on here so
i'll i'll log the ip address
so it logs the university ip address
sort of 128.243.56.55
whatever it is i've just made that one
up uh and things i hope that isn't a
really useful server um so it'd log that
but it might also decide to say
i'll log the user agent what sort of web
browser
is logging this and so it log that
but if i'm a crafty individual
then i could change that user interface
to have a sort of dollar curly brace in
it
and then some stuff java colon version
curly brace
and
log4j when it logs that string
would replace that with whatever the
current version of java is or whatever
that's expanded
now that doesn't sound like too much of
a problem um
except it means that you can't trust
your logs anymore
because
what you thought you logged
is partially under control of you the
programmer and partially under control
of me the hacker sending you data
so you've suddenly found that actually
your logs perhaps aren't
logging exactly what you thought they
were
uh and things
but the real killer comes
and this is what makes log4j so
devastating and why people are really
trying to fix this because people are
using this is that there is another
feature that was added i think was
around 2013
which was the ability to use the java
naming and discovery interface i think
it is i can't remember what the i stands
for to look
this data up in other services so things
like the ldap lightweight directory
access protocol you can do a dns lookup
using jndi
rmi interrupt type stuff you can do
lookups in there so you can ask other
services
to look things up
and what someone found
is that if you craft
a
simple enough string
and you put it in something that's going
to get logged like your user agent
then
that will then be expanded out and log4j
will hand
this string over to jndi and jndi will
look at it and say okay this is ldaps
colon slash then some address
i think okay i'll go and talk to that
ldap server
and request information
and so
as a person who perhaps maybe up to some
nefarious purposes i can send a
perfectly well crafted string to mike's
server or whoever server this is
that gets that machine to connect
to
another machine
now
that's bad enough but
and this is where it starts to get worse
remember we said that the variable
expansion was recursive
so i can put that into
the
string that i wanted to connect to so
connect to this ldap server slash dollar
curly brace java colon version curly
brace
and find out what version of java
they're running
or what operating system they're running
or get access to the environment
variables and start to get information
about what's going on on their system
how their system is configured
and so this leaks
information
from what should be
inside their firewall their setup
to me outside as long as i've got a
server that i can control here
and make them make requests up to that
server and as long as i don't do this
running on my own machine so they know
exactly where i live and they can come
and sort of arrest me
and things then i can find that
information and collect that information
except that's not the bad bit
that's only the sort of mild
and sort of yeah the really bad stuff
and i don't understand why this is even
part of java but for some reason it is
you can craft it in such a way that when
you make that jndi request to the ldap
server
it can return back a java object
containing code which the server will or
whatever system is running this log4j
happily then run
untrusted code
on your server which i could use or mike
could use or sean could use to do
whatever havoc that they want to do on
that machine
so the problem we've got
is we've got the feature in log4j which
enables us to make jndi requests
from outside the software
and then we've got the feature you can
call it that in jndi which for some
reason will happily go down and download
a java class file and execute it
on that machine for us so coupling these
things together what people found
is and i think they did this while
playing with each other and hacking each
other's minecraft servers is that you
can basically execute code on someone
else's machine
very very easily
and things which is never a good
situation
to be in
and the problem and i think mike's going
to demonstrate this in a second
is that
log4j is like milk it's like water it's
everywhere this isn't just a problem
that would affect the machines that are
talking
to the outside world
they can collect data which gets passed
to another system within the thing which
can then process the data it only takes
one of those things to be running log4j
and log the data
for you to get a a foot in the door as
it were
and your code to get executed it's not
reliant on it being the machine you're
talking to as long as something gets
past something that gets past something
and one of the really nasty things is
you can sort of build these up and it
could end up being composed from two
separate things if you're really clever
and knew what was going on
then it would still have the same effect
it reminds me a bit of the little uh
bobby drop tables uh exploit is it is it
similar to that
almost identical to that yeah one of the
big problems with it is actually also
how easy it is right i mean this is not
a difficult string to craft you can just
go on twitter and there are 50 examples
in your timeline and so
it's that perfect combination of quite
easy to exploit doesn't need a huge
amount of um
of expertise and everyone's vulnerable
to it right it's it's just you know i
mean i i was meeting a friend and who
works for a company in nottingham and
they were up on sunday night until 2am
trying to fix their servers right trying
to push updates to log 4j to all of
their servers to prevent these kind of
attacks they weren't necessarily getting
attacked yet right because a lot of
people are just fishing around
but i mean i think today
there's a worm
going around trying to execute this kind
of attack on vulnerable servers so you
know is it does it come with the java
in-store then is it is it kind of like a
given you just get this automatically
not quite it's very close it's very
close to that i think one of the reasons
and in fact i can demonstrate that now
actually but one of the issues you have
is that um it's it's incredibly
straightforward to use
it is almost for default right it's not
i mean i'm i've got an example here but
i created a spring boot application it's
not the default in spring boot but it
might as well be if you read any videos
for example
there is it's a couple of lines to to
swap this logger in and start logging
things
um
which it's good but that's easy to use
in some sense right because for me who
doesn't know a huge amount of java needs
to get an api running nice and quickly
i can do that with very minimal effort
right i'd have to go and learn you know
read a whole textbook on this but on the
other hand i'm now finding myself in a
situation which is essentially my fault
in something in some way that i'm using
a logo i don't really understand with
features that i don't really understand
and it's causing me vulnerabilities
that's where i find myself so let me
show you how easy this is right what
i've created here is basically it's a
spring boot application now spring boot
is incredibly powerful you know
dependency injection framework but
really from my point of view it just
allows you to create very very simple
rest apis and other web servers so i've
done that i've created a little web
server that runs on my laptop and if i
go to
localhost slash api slash my url it
sends me back a string right very very
straightforward now my api that i use at
work is obviously a little bit more
advanced than this but basically it's
the same principle now if i go into my
maven pom file i can see all my
dependencies and i could actually say
okay i'd like to use
log4j for my logging so i'm gonna i'm
gonna paste that in what it's saying
here is remove the current
logger which is the default one that
comes with spring boot and then replace
it with log4j right uh so i'm gonna save
that as soon as i put in one of these
dependencies
maven says oh you've added something
would you like me to get it for you so i
click this refresh button and off it
goes and starts resolving dependencies
and downloading all the jar files for me
essentially so it's now
downloading
it's downloaded log4j just at the bottom
there and now i can use log4j i've coded
up this very very simple rest controller
so all i need to do
is start adding some logging right so to
do that
i import the logger this won't take very
long by the way so if i type import um
org dot sl4j.blogger
so this is the interface that we we're
going to be using for logging and there
are a few loggers and you know they all
operate in basically the same way using
the same interface so you don't have to
use log4j but of course many many people
are including me
sl
f4j.loggerfactory
if i run this application all i'm doing
is i'm
listening for get requests on this
particular url so if i run it we're
going to see a load of logs
um this is spring boot firing up it's
firing up databases and all kinds of
stuff so if i go to my
url you can see it comes back with
world's best rest api as its string
you know
i mean i'm not wrong it's fantastic now
maybe i want to log that someone's gone
to this url so all i need to do is
obtain the logger for this particular
class and then i can use it right it's
very simple so logger l equals logger
factory
dot get logger
and then this dot get class
and then i can say logger
l.log
and then you can have different kinds of
logs right so anyone that's logged will
know you have like debug logs warnings
errors let's just throw a warning for
for the sake of being simple so i can
say l dot warn and then i'm gonna go
this is a warning it's not very
informative this is exactly i mean this
is probably why my api isn't vulnerable
because my logs are not helpful
so
let's run that again and then i'll go to
my api again
it's just starting
up there we go
we rerun this
and then we can see in here
i've got my warning show up in my logs
right now my log is just going out to
the console but it could go to a file it
could go to a database right this is
this is
log4j is pretty flexible and you can do
most of this through config so it's
quite easy to use so that was i mean
that was basically all there was to it
you go into you know some java
application and you say to something
like maven or gradeable i'd like to use
log4j
it just finds the code on the internet
and downloads it for you and that's
literally it
so it's no surprise that people are
using a lot of these libraries why would
i code my own logger when there's this
great logo i could use you know
and so one of the real problems here is
just the prevalence of this library in
you know anything java so that kind of
brings us around to why has it got these
functions in it is that right is that
where we're going steve
yeah i mean i think that's one of the
the issues is that
you've got a
when you include a library
you get all this functionality
but you also get all the bugs and all
the other features or that come with it
and you might think okay well by not
writing my own log files
i i save time you do
my program is more secure probably is
because
someone's actually thought about it's
being used a lot the bugs have been
found but the problem we get is that
you're still
using a library is still importing
someone else's books
into your program
the nice thing about open source
software is that you can
look at the bugs and you can fix them
yourself and then share them but
you still need to
fix the bugs you still need to analyze
that code to check that it is actually
doing
what it ex what you expect it to and i
think as mike's shown is that
it's very easy to use this without
thinking about all the ramifications
about all the features that you perhaps
aren't even aware of i mean i suspect
ninety percent of people who use log for
j i'm making up statistics on the top of
my head i should get a job in government
probably didn't even know that a it
could make a jndi call and probably
never heard of jndi before the
vulnerability had come out anyway and so
i think if you're designing a library
the take-home message from this is
keep it simple
get it to do one thing well and then
design another library that can be built
on top of that so that people can
compose the services that they need to
do what they needed to do so if you're
building a library that logs things
log the data
untransformed if people need to
transform the data before it's logged
well that's another library which
transforms the data and then you compose
that on top of
the logging information so that you can
do it in a way that as a programmer you
know is secure
for your use case for your application i
think what's gone
wrong here and this is not a criticism
of log4j you can see the similar
problems popping up all over the place
it was an example a few months ago where
iphones were being sort of bricked
because there was a wifi network popped
up with a percent s in it which
caused printf or s printf inside the
kernel or something to do a equivalent
expansion of that and it all went
horribly wrong
so i think you need to make sure that
you
build libraries that do one thing well
and then compose other things on top of
that if you need that functionality and
only if you need that functionality
slightly ironic thing is if you actually
look inside the log4j source code a lot
of it is already built like that in that
you've got the logging functionality and
then when you do message lookups and
sort of look at these variables and
things that's an extra layer of code
which is sort of
put as an object on top of the other
object using the decorator pattern and
things and you just think if this was
exposed to the outside world if this is
how the api was constructed then mike
could just say no i just want plain
logger at this point
and things and then later on he could
use the other bits to build up more
complicated logs for the bits of code
because he knows it's safe to do so so
so it sounds like the problem is
somebody's packaged all of this together
instead of perhaps offering it as
options or you know as separate
components is that is that fair i think
so it's understandable why that's
happened
it certainly makes it easier for a
programmer to be able to do this and you
can see why someone requested that the
jndi was in there though i think it'd be
great if i could just look up this
username against the person's name
they're probably writing something
internal that never spoke out of the
internet but the trouble is is that
because that gets
composed into so many different bits of
software
that functionality suddenly becomes a
vector for doing other things so as i
said
when you're writing
the libraries keeping it from a security
point of view if you keep it simple to
do one thing
then the programmers who are using that
hopefully we'll
then only use the bits they need it's
great having huge libraries which do
everything
but
if they do everything there's more
spaces for there to be bugs
and
yeah
there's just more spaces for there to be
bugs one of the interesting things about
this is that um it you know it comes up
a lot in in discussions among sort of
tech enthusiasts and people who are
working in the industry
is that you know no one's paying for
log4j right so what what what right have
we to ask that it's secure against some
attack or and so on and i think to an
extent that's true actually i think that
i mean this actually happened
before with open ssl open ssl had the
heartbleed bug now that was an actual
bug in some sense it was is slightly
different to this
but it turns out at that time that many
many companies some of which make a lot
of money were using this for free
and have now been exposed by a bug and
maybe that bug wouldn't exist if it had
been properly funded right now we can't
predict you know the future from the
past and so on we don't know what would
happen if there were lots more people
working on log4j maybe one of them would
have spotted it but i do think
it's interesting to think about just how
many people including myself who are
using these libraries without much
consideration about where they came from
or who's actually doing the work right
and i think that when this thing was
implemented in sort of 2013 it was with
the best of intentions
and
it's it's caused somewhat of a problem
like more recently and
yeah it's something to think about the
advantage
of open source in cases like this
is that the source code is available
which means that you can look at the
library and say
okay this is a problem i can fix it
and then you can share
that fixed version
you have the ability to take the source
code to look at it and fix it open
source is not going to give you
a badge of quality to say
and we can see that here that this
software is secure that's not what open
source means open source means that the
source code is available for you to
modify
and fix and
hopefully share that with the rest of
the community and so i think the
advantage here from people's point of
view is if you've got a library
you can hack it about and take out the
bits you need and just use them
rather than sort of if you've got a dll
for microsoft or something uh you'd have
to use it as is and have no
no ability to change it the great thing
about this which is where i think open
source shines
is not that the software is free
it's not that how it's licensed i think
it thinks the fact that the source code
is available and i can edit it and i can
fix it myself and then share those fixes
the conversation surrounds
um these people who are doing
what appear to be keystone bits of
software in their spare time effectively
at the same time as doing a full-time
job perhaps as a developer for someone
else they might have just kind of been
the last one holding the bat on and
they're you know tasked with maintaining
something that you know 90 percent of
the world's java runs on
yeah although that can be a double-edged
sword because
and i'm not saying this in this case but
you could see for example bits of
software that really should be allowed
to die
but i mean
let's for example let's let's suppose
that ms-dos was open source
you can guarantee that there would
probably be a community of people still
maintaining ms-dos
today
we probably don't want bits of software
like ms-dos still being maintained
they're interesting historical
curiosities
they're not software that should be used
today and that's the danger is the
software exists beyond itself by date
because anyone can maintain it and it
still looks useful it's one of those
situations which is interesting because
there's basically been no winners at all
right everyone that's been using log4j
has got to drastically quickly patch all
their stuff and redeploy it and you know
maybe you've got 10 000 instances on aws
you've got to deploy right this is not
trivial um
and you know i'm lucky with my little
api it's not even running that i can fix
and re re-run it when i need to you've
got the developers who are desperately
trying to write patches for this thing
and of course that and you know by
fixing one bug you might introduce some
other bugs right and it's this takes
time you don't want you can't just fix
this problem in five minutes and push a
push or commit and it's all it's all
it's all solved
so
um
i think that um the response has been
pretty positive i would say you know
companies are just getting on with
trying to fix this but we're not we're
not going to see the end of this for a
while right there's going to be
issues like this and as steve said
issues in other libraries are going to
come up from time to time turns out
everyone was using and only two people
were writing the thing and you know this
is this isn't going to be the last time
that happens i think for me the thing
this shows is that pandora's box is now
well and truly open
people are going to be looking at every
library every open source library every
closed source library to try and find
similar things where this can come along
we think this is bad we've probably not
seen anything yet
some of the rounds we do in columns so
we mix a
b c and d
and then we mix this column and then we
mix this column a b c and d in this
column so sometimes we mix diagonals so
it'll be a start to see
and then as we go a bit further on we
suddenly see that everything starts to
disappear